hey y'all happy Tuesday pocalypse still
going on 11 watchin everything fall
apart well you know kind of yeah but
yeah so uh let's see earlier I posted
the show about Jeffrey Dahmer the
Milwaukee monster yeah hopefully you
guys are enjoying that sorry we went off
of those if we talked about food again
on a show about a [ __ ] cannibal we
did yeah I don't remember you don't
remember we were talking about like meat
and how we like to like raw steaks oh
yeah yeah yeah stuff and I'm just like
man I can't believe I'm [ __ ] talking
about this on the Jeffrey Dahmer [ __ ]
so in our defense we always end up
talking about food on the show no matter
what the subject matter is yeah so
that's that's what I'm gonna say so I'm
just you know what I mean and we didn't
mean it what is there to talk about I
don't know I wanted you know what I
wanted to like I don't know why this
like made me laugh so much I was just
like scrolling through the [ __ ] like
little news stories and stuff like that
this morning and I someone that I
thought was very funny because it
happened in like a little Welsh town and
you know I used to live over there so I
was like oh what's this all about so
apparently some guy in this Welsh town
which in English it looks like landed no
but that's not how you pronounce it it's
more like and didn't or something like
that I can't burn I know I [ __ ] that
up I tried to learn Welsh like many
years ago but the pronunciation is just
like escaping me but so this guy has
been posting on his Twitter account he
lives like above a pub in that town and
he noticed like one night a few like a
week or two ago that because everybody's
staying inside and there's not like a
lot of people out on the roads and stuff
that all these little goats have started
like taken over the town so they so he
saw them like the first time like a
little whole little like group of him
and they're like walking down the in the
middle of the road like at night and
stuff and then they all gathered around
like all these hedges and started eating
them and [ __ ]
and so he's been like on his Twitter
feed he's been like chronicling the goat
takeover of the downtown area just
because he's little good so he's like
every day he posts these little videos
of like all these cute little good
that are like just running around in the
middle of the street and stuff and every
now and then you see like you know work
van or something like that and the goats
like and he's like he even put on there
he's like these goats do not give a [ __ ]
they just like stand there in the middle
road like yeah bring it
so they've cut they've taken over a
Welsh town the goats goats are smart
there's they are they're about as smart
as a dog
it may be smarter I've dealt with him
before certain barns that had goats
ain't need ain't need to go to court
they just had goats as pets and they
were [ __ ] funny man they were may
recognise you and they come run it you
know I remember he was that with that
one little goat that was at that barn we
used to were so so what was his name oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] what was that good - yeah yeah
you could call the gun go come running
yeah there were if they had two of them
didn't they but then I remember there
was one and he was pretty cool and I
think that well he always wanted
peppermints like he really liked yeah so
if you gave them if you gave him
peppermints one time he would remember
that always yeah and so when you came to
the barn again even if it was like
months later he would come up and
headbutt you in the pocket yeah it'd be
like hey Andy yep
when also I don't know if you've ever
seen it but there's really nothing cuter
than [ __ ] baby goats especially when
somebody puts a little bit pajamas on
them yeah because there's like a really
faint there's like a viral video that
went around with like all these tiny
baby goats like a little jammies on and
it's like pretty much the cutest thing
ever oh um
turns out turns out they did they joint
they merged the Treasury with the
Federal Reserve Bank which that's some
wild [ __ ] because how that Federal
Reserve Bank happened and the [ __ ] that
it does and it not being under the
control the United States it's some of
the control basically [ __ ]
international banksters it's weird
because of this emergency they put it
under the Department of Treasury they
change the dammit
email address on the thing and
everything which it's pretty good you
know I mean a lot of countries do that
can print their own money and that's
what it said in the Constitution to do
that but you could also [ __ ] that up and
create it and just print endless money
and go into hyperinflation like Zam
way and what's it what's that other one
Venezuela did did that too they treat
you can't just print money to print you
print money to get yourself out of
trouble you actually but I think I think
it has to do with this emergency right
now that they you know I mean I think
that's how they got that dot because of
this plague they need direct control
over the damn money and the printing of
money because if they actually lock hole
sent places of the United States down
for months like they're talking about
eighteen months I don't I can't see that
being possible I think they're be
revolts and rebellions but if they had
to do that you have to be able to
control the value of the money and it's
permanent it's pretty weird a lot of
things changing you know they well I
don't think well for one thing I don't
think it's gonna be that long because I
was just reading this morning that
retail stores in Wuhan are starting to
reopen yeah so even though cuz the thing
I was reading about was that obviously
and this is something that we've talked
about a lot of people have been talking
about too is that you know
brick-and-mortar retail stores are
probably going to suffer a lot from this
yeah because they were talking about
Macy's and how they had furloughed most
of their employees and stuff I mean
obviously they still have an online
presence you know all of these stores do
but they're talking about you know when
all this is said and done is everything
gonna go like dead mall you know I mean
if they don't if if they lock down to
the extent that they're saying they will
it will but I don't think they're gonna
let it I think I think what's gonna
happen this is what as things start to
fail they go you know what we we can't
do this you know people have to have
lives and they're gonna they're gonna
lift quarantines and stuff they're just
gonna we can absorb the casualties well
like you know and that you can but you
know we don't we don't need we have
friends who are losing all their [ __ ]
businesses yeah yeah I mean and we're
talking about hairdressers you know
people that own bars it's just that's
really where most of the economy is is
on all these little business
you know and that's how people that
they're just not gonna let it get that
far out of hand as I just can't see it
the people will revolt if you don't have
any if you don't have anything then you
lose you don't have anything to lose you
then yeah then you got nothing to lose
and then you said [ __ ] it you know and
then they try to take over and then it
burns [ __ ] down there's already been
limited rioting in China and in Italy
imagine New York would [ __ ] go
apeshit you know it's uh but another
thing they were saying in the same
article where they were talking about
you know Macy's in the retail
environment but one thing they were
saying and some people are saying that
this might be kind of a silver lining is
that maybe a lot of companies that were
reluctant to let their employees work
from home before will now see that
that's kind of the way to go or I mean
obviously some things can't a lot of
things will get real efficient because
most people I mean not everybody
obviously you know a small percentage of
people I think they probably do need
supervision or they're just gonna [ __ ]
off but honestly I think the majority of
people like that work in offices are
dude the type of [ __ ] that I do or
whatever um I think I get more done yeah
when I'm at home like undisturbed
because honestly in all of the jobs that
I used to have it's like I would get a
lot of [ __ ] done but a lot of time was
wasted one driving back and forth to
getting interrupted constantly by other
[ __ ] or like other like sales people
coming in wanting this that the other
thing and they're like you know
interrupting my train of thought they're
doing this and that give me you know
give me giving me something else to do
while I was working on something else
which I hate and you know so it was all
that kind of stuff so depending on the
industry I do think that there is gonna
be a lot more open yeah
there'll be a lot more open to like
letting people work at home if they
don't absolutely have to be on site you
know it's wasteful I think the whole
idea of supervision is back back in that
day when they hired very young people
who were stupid and didn't have any
skills education or intelligence so you
just put him on a machine and then you
had somebody walking around watching
them making sure they did that thing on
whatever
it was that they worked on punching
things out and punching parts and making
sure that their quality was good enough
you know but now now that people can be
sourced over the Internet
the employer doesn't have to supervise
these people if the work isn't done it
isn't done to standard they just replace
it with another one instantly oh yeah so
if you want to make money you better
work and be able to work well so what
was where's the super faith yes I mean
super vision well that's the thing it's
like I don't need to be supervised
because it's funny because if I don't
work I don't make any money I make zero
money you know I think for most most
jobs that require intelligent people
they don't need you don't need any
supervision the people that need
supervision that are in those jobs can't
get employment nobody wants to [ __ ] with
them you know I mean and then they
become unemployed that's just the
survival of the fittest basically yeah
pretty much but like I said we'll see
how it's gonna shake down I don't know
yeah you know we've like I said I think
people have been like followed in the
news and it's like I don't like to like
dwell on it too much on the show just
because I feel like people are probably
think about yeah but I know when people
are like sick and hearing about it
you know what I mean maybe I'm sick of
hearing about it that's for sure but um
yeah so since I was talking about Wales
earlier I know Wales in England or two
different countries so you know don't at
me but I haven't done a book
recommendation in a while so I wanted to
recommend this delightful nonfiction
book called watching the English this is
by an anthropologist who is herself
English and she has written an
anthropological study of the English
people like their culture like how they
drive like all the stuff they have in
their house and it is hilarious and
accurate because but it's like it's just
it's a it's a really good natured kind
of book and it like kind of goes into a
lot of like why they talk about the
weather and like the thing they have
with their pets and like all this other
kind of stuff so yeah it's like really
it's I think it's even instructive I
mean it was funnier for me reading it as
an American but even like the British
people I knew that right at like thought
it was really good and they were like
nailed it yeah so yeah definitely check
that out and yeah go check out I can't
remember the guys name that's doing the
Twitter feed of the goats but just like
just Google like goats take over Welsh
town or whatever and you'll find it it's
likes it's super funny it's like I don't
know why it amused me so much because it
just seems like a horror movie but also
kind of like the most adorable horror
movie ever with Josie and these aren't
like little bitty goats these are like
the big goats with like the the big like
curly horns and [ __ ] like that it's like
those bigger goats and they're all just
like they're just like running amuck I
like in a little gang like all around
the city like eating all their shrubs
and chauffeur there for the push it
alright so you done with your yeah so
you're done I'm bored with it oh oh no
oh what I'm ready to get out here oh no
you know what I wanted to mention this
is somebody somebody commented I think
on yesterday's I try sure like on
YouTube yeah then it's like that I
needed to get out of the house because
like sort of us because we're gonna like
kill to buy that's what I mean I work
from home for what four years almost
four years I've worked from home we
haven't really noticed anything yeah I
mean honestly like other than not being
able to go in loved it um you know and
having to kind of like worry about oh we
should probably shouldn't go to the
grocery store or some other than that
has affected us really not all that much
because as I said I've been working from
I got laid off back in 2016
and yeah I've been working from home
ever since yeah you know what I mean
[ __ ] this is just this just
accelerates is just accelerating the
evolution that was already happening
certain industries you just disappeared
you had to work from home and honestly
and I have my own her a long time and
yet happened to me in several many years
ago and honestly this um you know this
is my own office okay I have my own
office yeah so you know he mostly in
during the day when I'm working he
mostly just hangs out I [ __ ] off in the
[ __ ] room bedroom [ __ ] fallout 4
and you know [ __ ] you know following
the people that I follow on on
Facebook I have talked to a lot of you
guys some people talk to me you know I
mean like son here's another thing I get
a [ __ ] ton of messages from people if I
don't ask you don't be [ __ ] yeah Sam
it's like I really do try to get yes I
answered everybody I'd be answering
[ __ ] 150 messages everybody yeah the
people that I talk to are people that
like that I know personally want because
we got club friends and then people that
I worked with cuz you know we do stuff
from the home with bands and whatever
you know the other [ __ ] other shows
other YouTube channels and people that
we met through the channel years back
when we first started yeah in other
words people that almost started with us
how many a couple years back so yeah and
only like a few of them you know so
don't be weird with the internet man the
challenge is not find people to talk to
shutting everybody out cuz you know I
mean you'd be like the [ __ ] bored
whereas voices in your head you don't
want to hear legit well usually what I
do cuz like I said you know you know
usually spend kind of you know doing
like a lot of your your [ __ ] in the
bedroom I come in the office in the
morning and usually the first thing I do
like within the first hour is I go
through and I answer all emails I answer
all YouTube messages or you know at
least like them whatever go through and
like see what everybody said on
Instagram stuff and I try to only do it
like once a day unless like some urgent
[ __ ] comes up because otherwise I'd
never get anything else done yeah but
we're not at close quarters here we got
a big place I got my own [ __ ] gym in
the garage and jam it out in there and
then the [ __ ] room and yeah so it's
not like we're just like trapped in a
tiny guitar for Madonna like we're you
know you know like you're driving me
crazy
we have room see you're tearing me apart
they have rooms in here that we [ __ ]
basically never going just walk through
like the living room like the living
room the live everybody we have two
living rooms and we have a den there's
other [ __ ] guest rooms and stuff so
we're not yeah I don't think I've been
in the guest room for no months monster
right yeah so there's just no reason for
me to go
we're in Florida so prices are good for
yeah I mean this is a fairly large house
it's four bedrooms and three bathrooms
but we got it for a like very very
reasonable yeah you know this this would
be in in California area where I [ __ ]
was born like in Long Beach this would
be a no no no two million dollar house
three million dollar house here it's
like four thousand yeah yeah and
obviously and we don't like you know we
just rent but yeah we just rent but then
our rents not that bad it yeah and
honestly um I've seen like apartments
going from or that road the same or more
rent no this and this is like a really
huge house so the landlord loves me
because I can fix all this [ __ ] yeah
we've been here a long time in a long
time and I don't charge you might take
pictures this broke out don't worry I
got it you know yeah he yeah he likes us
because we're and also house we fixed
stuff and and also fragment there's a
part of my income this [ __ ] federal
that I can't be unemployed um yeah so
because you know being a disabled
veteran I'm boom I get I get I get
checks yeah so I'm probably he's
probably gonna lose a lot of his renters
he's got 40 houses yeah he's gonna lose
a lot of his rent it he won't lose me is
I won't even feel as a matter of fact my
checks will be bigger this month I mean
really yeah it's gonna be all kinds of
supposedly yeah I mean because usually
no she aids you have you know you have a
guaranteed and yeah like I said it's
harder for me because you know like I
said everything she's in the real
economy everything I do is freelance and
if I don't get freelance then I get ya
know money I was basically medically
retired yeah you know so I have like
eighty percent yes and I get raises and
[ __ ] it's the same thing that happened
to a policeman if he got hurt on a job
yeah and I get I got that same deal yeah
so because it and it wasn't combat
related it was [ __ ] it was second
just an accident
I mean it happened on the bait you
happen on the base yeah I got hit by a
military vehicle [ __ ] it lost my
career yeah they had to medically retire
me so how's it yeah so and that's what
happens so I'm just saying you know
don't worry we're not gonna kill each
other yeah
like weekend yeah like I said we've
we've been doing this for many years and
it's it's not like we're just like
constantly on top of each other because
you're not I mean I'm in the office and
in the office pretty much like ten
eleven hours a day and because I'm part
of VFW and I also have all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] going on with the VA if it got
really bad I could go to work for VA
yeah a lot of guys in my positions work
for the VA - and then the money's great
but I like to stay home I have a [ __ ]
quick temper sometimes you know because
you know I had head injuries yeah so
that they had a whole section where they
got guys like me working you get a bunch
of dudes together they all have TBI mass
[ __ ] it off a chain that's what I mean
so I was like maybe maybe it's better
that you don't go to this it's usually
love fest you know [ __ ] you [ __ ]
I love you gonna beat your ass you know
I mean but it's all friends and to be
honest you're you're pretty chill buzzes
yeah yeah yeah now you got to do
something really [ __ ] bad for us I
mean you know you you talk big and you
talk a lot it's like that that's normal
but that's just how you do you know in
my culture that's out it yeah like I
said you're not otherwise you're like
pretty [ __ ] chilled out
I don't really usually have a [ __ ]
[ __ ] up no well now there's
really no reason because there's nobody
all right so fine gays it is yeah all
right so we're gonna wrap up the Tuesday
show and we will talk to you my
computer's ding and my other computer
we'll talk to you again tomorrow